we will now take a step towards
abstraction and discuss the issue of
convergence of random variables let us
look at the weak law of large numbers it
tells us that with high probability the
sample mean falls close to the true mean
as n goes to infinity we would like to
interpret the statement by saying that
the sample mean converges to the true
mean however before we can make such a
statement we should first define
carefully the word converges and we need
a notion of convergence that refers to
convergence of random variables here is
the definition suppose that we have a
sequence of random variables that are
not necessarily independent we say that
this sequence of random variables
converges in probability that's the
particular notion of convergence we're
defining it converges to a certain
number if the following is true no
matter what epsilon is as long as it is
a positive number the probability that
the random variable falls far from this
number that is epsilon or further away
from that number that probability
converges to 0 as n increases that is as
n increases there is higher and higher
probability that Y n will be close to
this particular number a this is the
notion of convergence that we have
defined and notice that this notion of
convergence corresponds exactly to what
is happening in the weak law of large
numbers and so in particular we can
describe the weak law of large numbers
as saying that m and the sample mean
converges to MU as n goes to infinity
but in a particular sense in the sense
of convergence in probability let us now
try to understand a little better what
convergence in probability really
amounts to and we will do that by making
a comparison with the ordinary notion of
convergence of real numbers
when we're dealing with convergence of
numbers we start with a sequence of
numbers and we are interested in the
statement that this sequence converges
to a certain limit what does that mean
what we mean is that the elements of the
sequence eventually that is when n is
large enough we'll get and stay
arbitrarily close to this particular
number a which is the limit in terms of
a picture here is a the limit here is n
we take a small band around this number
a and what we require is that the
elements of the sequence eventually get
within this band around the number a
they might get outside the band get
inside again but eventually that is
after some time the elements of the
sequence will only stay inside this band
now to translate this into a more formal
mathematical statement which is the
mathematical definition of the notion of
convergence we have the following if I
give you some epsilon epsilon could be a
very small number I form a band around a
that goes from a minus epsilon to a plus
Epsilon what I want is that there exists
a certain time and zero in this picture
and zero would be here such that for all
times after n zero our sequence stays
within Epsilon from a that is our
sequence stays inside this band now let
us move to the case of random variables
and see what convergence in probability
is talking about here instead of a
sequence of numbers we have a sequence
of random variables and we're interested
in the meaning of the convergence of the
sequence of run
variables to a particular number in
words what this means is that if I fix a
certain epsilon as in this picture then
the probability that the random variable
falls outside this band converges to
zero so the picture would be as follows
we have again or limit we fix some
epsilon which could be an arbitrarily
small number for any fixed choice of
epsilon we take this band and for any
given n we look into the probability
that a random variable falls inside that
band so if I am to draw the distribution
of our random variable the distribution
might be something like this so there is
a certain probability that it falls
outside this band but when n becomes
large this probability of falling
outside this band becomes very small so
the probability of falling outside the
band becomes tiny so the bulk of the
distribution that is most of the
probability is concentrated inside this
band and this is true no matter how
small epsilon is if I take a much
narrower band around a I still want all
the probability to be eventually
concentrated inside that band of course
it might take longer it might take a
larger value of n but I want that when n
is very large the bulk of the
distribution is again concentrated
inside this narrow band so inwards
convergence in probability means that
almost all of the probability mass of
the random variable Y n when n is large
that probability mass gets concentrated
within a narrow band around the limit of
the random variable
we finally point out a few useful
properties of convergence in probability
that parallel well-known properties of
convergence of sequences suppose that we
have a sequence of random variables that
converges in probability to a certain
number a and another sequence that
converges in probability to some other
number B we do not make any assumptions
about independence we do not assume that
the accents are independent of each
other we do not assume that the sequence
of accents is independent of Y n we then
have the following properties if G is a
continuous function then the function of
the random variables converges to the
function of the number so for example
the sequence of random variables xn
squared is going to converge to a
squared another fact is that the sum of
these two random variables converges to
the sum of their limits both of these
properties are analogous to what happens
with ordinary convergence of numbers and
they tell us that in some sense
convergence in probability is not a very
different notion we will not prove those
properties at this point but they're
useful to know however there's an
important caveat xn might converge to a
certain number in probability
however the expected value of xn does
not necessarily converge to that same
limit so convergence of random variables
does not imply convergence of
expectations and we will be seeing an
example where this convergence does not
take place